when I think about the individual interactions that I've been able to have
with students who both support the work that I'm doing
and who feel challenged by it and who do not support it.
What I've found is that,
while it can be difficult to change the values of a community,
we can gain a lot from individual interactions.
While I didn't get to engage with John Derbyshire
due to my president's disinvitation,
I was able to have dinner with Charles Murray before his talk.
I knew the conversation would be difficult.
And I didn't expect it to be pleasant.
But it was cordial, and I did gain a deeper understanding of his arguments.
I found that he, like me, believed in creating a more just society.
The thing is, his understanding of what justice entailed
was very different from my own.
The way in which he wanted to understand the issue,
the way in which he wanted to approach the issue of inequality
also differed from my own.
And I found that his understanding of issues like welfare
and affirmative action
was tied and deeply rooted
in his understanding of various libertarian and conservative beliefs,
what diminishes and increases their presence in our society.
While he expressed his viewpoints eloquently,
I remained thoroughly unconvinced.
But I did walk away with a deeper understanding.
It's my belief
that to achieve progress in the face of adversity,
we need a genuine commitment
to gaining a deeper understanding of humanity.
I'd like to see a world with more leaders
who are familiar with the depths of the views
of those they deeply disagree with,
so that they can understand the nuances of everyone they're representing.
I see this as an ongoing process involving constant learning,
and I'm confident that I'll be able to add value down the line
if I continue building empathy and understanding
through engaging with unfamiliar perspectives.
Thank you.
(Applause)